hey 42 here the most money ever paid for
a cow at an auction was 1.3 million
dollars
welcome to wit in the US the Eisenhower
interstate system requires that one mile
in every five must be straight these
straight sections are usable as air
strips in times of war or other
emergencies if you get burnt crack open
an egg he only eggs membrane from the
side of the shell and place it over the
wound the wound will heal without
scarring the under fowls brains were
bigger than modern humans they just
lacked the necessary social skills to
fry on average people swallow 1.5 liters
of your heed when swimming in a public
pool
also the Romans used to make toothpaste
from Yuri the Australian 5 $200 notes
are made of plastic
dueling is legal in Paraguay as long as
both parties are registered blood donors
if you try to suppress a sneeze you can
rupture a blood vessel in your head or
neck and die wearing headphones for just
one hour increases the amount of
bacteria in your ear by 700 times rats
multiply so quickly that in 18 months
two rats could have over a million
descendants and finally there is a town
in Norway called hell and it literally
freezes over
almost every winter thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42
you